RULES COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY
APRIL FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS HEREBY PULLED ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING TODAY FOR
STUDENTS BEING MADE AND IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS HEARING
MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
AND COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS ARE
OTHERWISE IMPEDES. THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATIONS THESE RULES MOST
AFFECTED INDIVIDUAL FOR REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
THEN IT LARA GIPSON HERE LEE
ERIC LEVINE MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS
THERE RAMOS- RUBIO. BE ABLE TO
A YEAR. WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A CORE- WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR MOST AUGUST
SENATE GENDER. SECOND MOVERS
ARE. MATHIS EITHER BY MR OF A
THE SECOND VEHICLE. OF
ARTILLERY. COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM THEN HI THEN I FLORA
FLOOR I GIPSON GIVE AYE LEE AYE
MI AYE LEVINE HI LEVINE IMH
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MATHIS. MATHIS
HI RON. RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO
HIGH VIEW PUT A LOT YOU BY
MOTION PASSES PROMOTIONS PRESS
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL
REMAIN FOR MINUTES FOR FALLING.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
YES
HAVING HIM VERY GOOD. WITH THAT
WE WILL ADJOURN THIS HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL.